well do you see this cat as you glance  at your television he has been the  mascot of the Nevada Northern Railway in  Ely for about 15 years and he just  passed away yeah his nickname was dirt  and you can probably figure out why they  called him that apparently used to roll  around in the dirt and he hated bats he  was found as a kitten didn't have any  family so the crews started spending  time with him feeding him and became the  mascot dirt grew into real Rough and  Tumble Tomcat that ruled the shop and  all the surrounding neighborhood 15  years and now the legacy is gone but he  did have a protege and his name is dirt  Junior they just call him DJ DJ by the  way dirt's a great name for a cat isn't  it also we're told the cats actually  greet visitors upon arrival so it's kind  of an interactive experience very  popular also they sell t-shirts and mugs  with dirt's face on those t-shirt and  mugs just because there's so many dirt  the cat fans yeah  and the museum